El otro día, Alés de Llano me propuso que teníamos que hablar de el mejor futbolista
que estuvo solo un año en los 20 equipos de la Liga.
Vale, como ha dado.
Es decir, bueno, el mejor futbolista de cada equipa.
De cada equipa, sí, sí.
Pero me refiero a este tipo de análisis que hacemos, de balance, hablando de futbolistas
que por una cosa u otra son icónicos en los 20 equipos que tenemos en la primera división
española.
Me pareció un tema muy interesante porque son historias efímeras, al final un año
como máximo.
No tiene más tema, pero muy potentes y variadas.
Un poquito de todo.
Nos hemos dividido los equipos y yo en los míos he encontrado de todo tipo y condición.
Ha tocado rebuscar mucho.
A mí ha salido fácil.
Yo he tenido que preguntar a tres o cuatro aficionados de ese club y no he terminado
contento con la elección.
Es complicado.
Es difícil, pero es un reto chulo.
Pero con otros he terminado muy contento y de hecho en uno ha habido hasta ayuda divina.
De Dios.
¿Me puedes decir en cuál?
Para cuando lleguemos estar preparado.
Es que te quiero sorprender, claro.
Bueno, arrancamos con el Deportivo Alavés, con el glorioso.
¿Un año le bastó para ser memorable a quién?
A Marcos Llorente en el Deportivo Alavés.
Ah, mira.
Marcos Llorente.
Ahí donde elegir.
Ese año.
Claro, el año que además llegaron a la final de Copa.
Teo Hernández.
Ahí donde elegir.
Recientes.
Samo Morodion.
Rafa Marín.
Claro.
Giuliano Simeone.
Jonathan Kaleri también está en la temporada.
Johnny Rodríguez.
Munir.
Insisto, ahí donde elegir en el Deportivo Alavés.
Le propuse todos a John Prada.
John Prada, por ejemplo, me recordó el caso de Fabrizio Colocini.
Temporada 2001-2002.
Mi prueba.
Cedido por el Milan.
Había donde elegir, como digo, con el glorioso, pero él me dijo Marcos Llorente.
No hemos visto de verdad un impacto como el de Marcos Llorente en aquel centro del campo.
Creo que estuvo más de una temporada.
Pero es que yo creo que…
No, no, no, no.
Lo busco.
No, no, no.
Pero ¿me vas a dejar hablar o vas a hacer la de siempre?
Igual hableado.
Claro, aquella primera temporada con Pellegrino en el banquillo, yo creo que se recuerda por
muchas etapas efímeras, Marcos Llorente, Teo Hernández, lo repasábais.
Creo que estuvo más de una temporada a Davison.
Sí, sí.
Camarasa.
El otro día me compararon con Davison.
¿En qué?
¿Te compararon con Davison?
No, no, no.
No, no.
Me dijeron que si fueras un futbolista serías de Davison.
Y digo ¿qué sería que hay una fantasía?
Yo creo que no, pero me tocó el corazón.
Era el comentario que quería decir.
Pero para contar una historia tuya has hablado de un jugador que estuvo varias temporadas.
Lo comprobé, lo comprobé.
Me quise entregar a la diversión, pero no.
Fue el año de los débuts.
Camarasa parece que también anda por ahí.
Es que había varios cedidos ese año y al final es lo que lleva.
Lo que lleva.
Vamos a hablar de muchos cedidos.
Claro.
En parte porque es lo que tiene el tema de poner como máximo un año.
Athletic Club, Álex.
Este me ha parecido el más difícil.
Este es el que ha costado.
Este es el que he presentado a múltiples aficionados.
Por ejemplo, el comodín de las sesiones.
Claro.
Por ejemplo, recientemente Jaló.
Pero claro.
No.
Y además, el típico etapa no ha acabado.
Me vas a permitir que me tire un triple desde mi cancha.
Y es el jugador más laureado a nivel de títulos.
Podríamos decir que has jugado para el Athletic Club.
Que es Lizarazu.
Sí.
Vale.
Me lo compras.
Claro.
Son 16 partidos en el Athletic Club.
Ostras.
Sí, pero el mejor solo 16 partidos.
Claro.
No es que sea el mejor para el Athletic Club.
Lo mejor en cuanto a grandeza él.
Aquí ya habíamos fijado en el siglo XXI.
Vale.
Porque tengo otro.
Lizarazu es 97-98.
Vale.
Porque tengo otro.
Caneda.
Es que es muy difícil.
El Athletic Club es muy difícil.
Caneda.
El compost.
Caneda de los groñés y tal.
Claro.
Es que me parece muy difícil si no es del siglo XXI.
Porque tienes, por ejemplo, Pecha Román.
Sí.
Pecha Román.
Que dejó la Real Sociedad para irse al Athletic Club.
Pero César Caneda…
Claro, podemos poner Rego, que acaba de empezar su trayectoria.
Claro.
Pero eso no va a contar.
César Caneda, además, no es ni una temporada.
Tiene varias.
No, no, no.
Pero de jugar, jugar solo es una.
No, no.
En las estadísticas del club, en la página web…
Son tres.
Así, pone tres.
En Tafemarche ponía una.
A ver.
Que eso no está a Biblia.
Hacemos una excepción a esto del siglo XXI con Lizarazu.
Hombre, me parece…
Por aquello de que el Athletic Club es particularmente complejo.
En el Athletic Club, sinceramente, no se me ocurría nada más.
Y yo centré el tema en Lizarazu.
Es verdad que lo he liado con lo del siglo XXI.
Pero porque no se me apareció a ninguno.
Y mira que estuve mirando.
De hecho, me he ido a los partidos jugados en el Athletic Club.
Y decir, bueno, a ver, que haya menos de treinta y pico.
O no treinta y pico.
Que eso quiere decir que ha jugado menos de una temporada.
Es muy difícil.
Lo primero que pienso de usar una temporada en el Athletic Club…
Creo que solo estuvo una Christian Ganea.
Que parece que tenía una buena pinta y luego no…
Es difícil.
Lo dejamos en Lizarazu.
97, 98…
Yo he ido por grandeza.
… pequeño asterisco.
Pero sí.
Arréglalo.
Lo de Caneda.
Echarme el cable.
Tres temporadas.
Sin ser memorable.
Ese ha sido un triple.
Es que yo quería mencionar la Unión Deportiva de Logroña y no sabía cómo hacer.
Es mucho más fácil, entiendo, Joan, a huel encontrar al del Atlético de Madrid.
Sí.
Sobre todo con el filtro del siglo XXI.
Porque el año 99-2000 está Gimbal.
Hay grandes nombres.
Vieri, Alemão, Manzuki…
Vieri es el siglo XX.
Claro.
Correcto.
También sería el siglo XX Diego Alonso en la segunda división.
José Sosa…
El Polilla.
¿Estuvo una temporada solo o estuvo más?
El fin de siglo XX Diego Alonso en la segunda división.
Bueno, en el trabajo de documentación son nombres que me gustan mucho.
Y yo creo que es un gran número.
Es un gran número.
En el trabajo de documentación son nombres que han salido.
Luis Suárez estuvo dos, por desgracia.
Porque si no… Vamos.
Sí, por desgracia, porque el segundo…
Porque la primera vuelta del primer año…
No, no.
Increíble.
Yo creo que, por lo que suposo también a nivel de dolo colectivo, me quedo con David Villa.
Temporada 13-14.
Es cierto que a nivel de cifras no son muchas.
Son 13 goals y cinco asistencias en 37 partidos.
No hay discusión.
Pero yo creo que…
Insisto, quitando a Hasselbrenk de la ecuación, David Villa claramente…
A campeón de Liga para el campeón.
Además aquí, fichado.
Quiero decir, porque es mucho más fácil encontrar sesiones.
¿Fueron cinco millones?
¿Fue Villa?
Sí.
Por ahí, creo.
Algo muy bajo, ¿no?
No recuerdo.
Sí, sí, sí.
Muy buen nombre.
El de David Villa.
Precisamente dejó el Fútbol Club Barceona.
David Villa es nuestro siguiente equipo.
Todos se acuerdan mucho del impacto de Edgar Davids en invierno de 2003-2004, de la temporada
2003-2004.
¿Puedo comparar el impacto que tuvo Pierre Emery con Bamayyan?
Ah.
11 goles en 18 partidos.
Sí, la verdad que…
Un buen clásico.
Que es verdad que el Barça no es el que para ganar.
Tremendo clásico con Xavi Hernández.
¿Fue 2003 o…?
Yo creo que fue 2004.
¿O 2004?
O algo así.
Sí, sí.
Luego tenemos recientemente la temporada de Ilkay Gundogan, que en su momento dijimos
que era el jugador de la temporada del Barça.
Fue una temporada horrible.
El último año de Xavi, horrible.
Sí, pero fue el mejor.
Pero bueno, cinco goles, 14 asistencias.
No le echó de menos el Barça, pero nos llamó la atención en ese momento.
En todo caso, y a pesar de que fuera decepcionante, un año le bastó Fratany Ibraimovich.
Creo que es insuperable.
22 goles, 13 asistencias, Liga ganada.
Sí, se tenía que marchar, eso no iba a encajar con Pep y demás.
Pero, hombre…
Sí, sí.
Lo de Ibra fue increíble.
Gran impacto.
Sí, sí.
Bamayyan no hubiese servido.
¿Por?
Porque la temporada siguiente juega 8 minutos en la primera jornada ante el terreno.
Ah, ah.
Pero un año le bastó para ser memorable y sigue siendo el mismo año.
A ver, a ver, a ver.
No va a valer lo de jugar dos minutos.
No.
Tengo un caso de…
Ha sido fuera de juego.
No.
Dos minutos no pueden ser tan importantes.
Por ejemplo, Larsson tampoco hubiera valido.
Podría ir a dos minutos.
Vale.
Otra vez torciendo tus propias reglas, Miguel.
No, no, no.
Es que eres muy exigente con tus reglas.
Aquí no.
Aquí no, pero sí.
En el momento no he hecho nada.
Es un juego ajeno, eh.
Ibra.
Vale.
Una vez más.
Mejor que en el propio.
Sí, la verdad.
Betis, Adri.
Dorland Pauwén.
Temporada 12-13 con el Betis.
8 goles en 17 partidos.
Cedido por el Parma.
Hay varios casos de jugadores que han estado cedidos en una temporada que han tenido buen
nivel.
Chadis Riyadh, por ejemplo, en la defensa del Betis.
Esto lo ha sido un tras.
Qué bueno.
Muy bueno, Chadis.
Bueno, pero no es cedido, ¿no?
O es cedido y lo compra porque era el de este con el Barça cuando lo vende.
Con el Barça sí.
No recuerdo de alguna cosa.
Sí.
¿No lo ha cedido?
Sí, pero había una acción de compra y un 50%.
Pero bueno.
Pero bueno, sí.
Yo creo que tenía que verlo de Emerson igual, ¿no?
Sí, puede ser.
Pues Leo Batistao.
Roque Santa Cruz.
Cedido por el City.
Siete goletos.
O sea, siete goles.
No, era por Leo Batistao.
Ah.
Sí, fue cedido opción de compra de 3 millones.
Y creo que lo compra para venderlo.
Lo compra para venderlo a Palas.
Por impacto en una temporada y lo que ha dejado en caja Jesús Rodríguez.
Sí.
Jesús.
Ah, cuidado, eh.
Dejando dinerito en caja, pero dos lampabón.
No sé si el mismo luego…
Dorlán Pavona y Valencia.
No sé si coincide con los meses del chupete suazo en Zaragoza.
Uy, puede ser.
¿12-13?
No sé si coincide exactamente, pero eran como los de novede.
Joder, madre mía.
Cómo cambiaron las cosas.
Alex, en celta.
Mi favorito.
Verás.
Bueno, es que claro.
Fiover Smolov.
Mi favorito.
Mido.
Muy bueno.
Vale, vale.
Aquí.
Mido jugó 8 partidos.
Vamos a comprobarlo.
8 partidos.
Sí, sí.
Metió 4 goles.
Le marcó al Athletic Club, le marcó a la Real Sociedad y fue clave para que se clasificara
el Celta a competición europea.
A Champions, de hecho.
Con lotina.
De hecho, estaba investigando mucho este fichaje y es muy curioso porque se lesiona
Mendes de gravedad.
Cuidado que está investigando en el gol mirando.
Cuidado, eh.
Se lesiona Mendes de gravedad.
El mejor ha jugado 8 partidos.
Pero el recuerdo de gravedad es muy potente en vivo.
Le he preguntado a nuestro colega Jesús López y me decía que tiene que ser Mido sí o sí
porque ese gol ante la Real es muy recordado y es un futbolista que en teoría no iba a
llegar.
Se lesiona Mendes de gravedad.
No le permiten hasta marzo inscribirlo.
Por eso juega solo 8 partidos.
Y de hecho, estuvo muy interesado el Celta en fichar a Forsel, que era el delantero finlandés
del Chelsea.
Hombre, sí, sí.
Y al final, Forsel se fue al Gladbach y terminaban fichando a Mido.
Y luego se fue al Ajax.
¿Y no te vale el nombre del radio?
¿Un Joaquín Larribay?
A mí no.
No vas a pisar el nombre del radio.
Lo tengo yo y no es...
Vale, vale.
A mí es que me gustaba más Mido.
Joaquín Larribay estuvo un año en Vallecas, un año en el Celta y en los dos...
Sí, sí.
... molaba mucho Joaquín Larribay.
Vale, nos vamos al Elche, Nahuel Miranda.
A ver.
En el Elche hemos tenido muchos problemas.
Muchos problemas.
Porque he escuchado que había jugadores que lo han hecho bien en una sola temporada.
Mojica, Niki Ville.
Estaba el caso de Fabián Ruiz, que estuvo un año, pero no estuvo en el Elche.
En segunda, ¿no?
Sí, en segunda, 11 goles en 27 partidos.
Niki Ville, eh.
O sea...
Fue sensación en su momento.
Un tío sensato.
Estoy hablando de las opciones que he descartado, Miguel, por favor.
No, no, estoy preguntando.
Mario Pasalic, La Roca Sánchez.
La Roca Sánchez.
La Roca.
Pero Mario Pasalic es muy bueno, eh.
Hay un nombre que es el primero en el que pensé yo, pero tiene una segunda etapa,
que es Jonatas.
Ah, claro.
Ay, sí, cuando se ponían gafas para celebrar.
¿Y la segunda etapa es en segunda o en primera?
Es en segunda.
Cuando le gafan a mi.
Esto sería un vacío legal, ¿no?
No sé.
Dilo tú.
Otra trampa que tienes.
No, pero si se lo estoy permitiendo.
No, se lo estoy permitiendo.
Ah, vale.
No, no, no.
Tú que eres el juez.
Tengo el nombre.
Y, aparte, os va a gustar porque viene con una historieta que me ha contado Gaspar Diez.
Jorge Molina, temporada 2010.
26 goles, una asistencia en 38 partidos.
La historia tiene miga.
Esto es segunda.
¿Y hay qué?
Estamos hablando de...
Se salieron en un año.
En el siglo XXI.
La Liga, pero la Liga es...
La Liga es la que se va a hacer.
La Liga es todo.
La Liga es un global.
Bueno, yo...
Los 42.
Yo...
Yo consideraría...
Deja lo que lo exponga.
No, no, pero es que en ningún momento hemos dicho que tiene que ser Primera División.
De la historia es el club.
Hemos dicho de los clubes de la Liga.
Pero no que estuvieran en la Liga en ese momento.
Deja lo que lo exponga.
Vamos.
Luego no me valdrá un jugador que jugó tres minutos.
Tres minutos jugó.
Bueno, es que en el enunciado, un año está.
Que la temporada haya sido en Primera División no está.
Vale.
Es una diferencia, yo creo, sustancial en el enunciado.
Bueno, a ver, pon.
Lo ficha el Elche del Poliegido.
Se sale esa temporada.
Se lo ficha el Betis, que era rival directo por el ascenso en ese momento.
En principio van a pagar dos millones de euros.
Pero claro, el Betis estaba en ley concursal.
Acaba pagando 300.000 euros.
Ostras.
Y asciende con Jorge Molina la temporada siguiente.
Aquí a temporada suben Betis, Rayo y Granada, que...
Estaban los tres en concurso de acreedores.
La verdad es que el Elche aquí, los pobrecitos míos,
pagaron justo por pecadores.
Estaba buscando Gary Mendes Rodríguez, que me gustaba mucho.
El año ese de Práves Trivá, con Jonatas, con Pasalic.
Molao ese equipo, la arbaridad.
Pasalic es muy bueno.
Vale, vale, vale.
Bien.
Segunda división, vale.
También alguno de...
¿Vais a traer algún filial también?
Bueno, a ver, a ver.
A ver, a ver.
Te pregunto, te pregunto.
En el siglo XXI, ¿cuántas temporadas hasta ahora?
¿Cuántas temporadas hasta ahora?
Claro.
Pues unas cuantas.
Tres o cuatro, no más.
Sí, sí, sí.
Aquella, la de Fran Escriba, la primera.
Son dos.
Bueno, son dos.
De hecho, no descienden, le bajan.
De hecho, te voy a decir una cosa.
No, está seis.
Yo tengo un equipo que en el siglo XXI
solo ha estado una vez en primera y es esta temporada.
Bueno, pues...
Como no valga segunda...
Seis temporadas en Elche.
Bueno...
Bueno, no.
No hay mucho donde elegir.
Vale, vale.
No, no.
Vacíos legales todos los del mundo.
Yo te invito, como esa profesora de matemáticas
que decía que había resuelto muy mal el problema,
a que te leas el puñetero enunciado que has puesto tú.
Lo propuso Alex.
El de los cuadernos...
Yo dije lo del mejor cuaderno.
El de los cuadernos Rubio no los enunciaba.
Y se lo salta con su primer ejemplo.
Vale.
Lo de siglo XXI.
Real Clúdeportivo Español.
Qué complicados hace ese programa de esos.
Dejó muy buen recuerdo Raducanu.
Lo que parece un poquito esto...
Lo de Nido.
11 partidos, 3 goles.
Dejó buen recuerdo.
Se le cayó una grada encima en el Madrigal.
Dejó un buen recuerdo, ya decimos, Raducanu.
Fue lo mismo.
Sobre todo para los que montaban las vallas
que tuvieron que cobrar el doble.
Le pasó a Palermo en el Ciutat.
Sí, sí.
No fue en el Madrigal lo de Palermo.
No.
Todos nos acordamos del año de Coutinho y Vladimir Valls.
El falla gol de falta de Coutinho por debajo de la barra.
En el minuto 21 lo marcó.
Con Pochettino fue, ¿no?
Sí, sí.
Pero creo que hay un año
que aunque no dejó buen recuerdo por su forma de salir,
es imbatible.
Borja Iglesias.
17 goles, clasificación europea.
Se va en Rubi y se termina yendo él al final del mercado.
No es uno de estos nombres superqueridos
como el de Nuno...
El de Nuno.
El de Nido.
O el de... ¿Qué has dicho de Atlético Madrid?
El de Villa.
Pero...
Pero bueno.
Es...
Es el que es.
Sí, sí.
A 17 goles.
Y es la mejor temporada del recorrido deportivo español
desde la etapa con Valverde.
Sí, es la última partidivación europea
del recorrido deportivo español
desde la final contra Sevilla.
Os lo he dado hasta un año y medio.
Sí, lo busqué.
Lo primero que buscas es ese nombre,
que es efímero,
para ver si entra.
Pero Osvaldo...
No se si os acordáis, pero había un tramo
que al español pasaba mucho, que era...
Empiezan mal la temporada, fichan invierno un delantero
y van al onzo.
Estaban en el onzo.
Pum, pa'lante.
Osvaldo, pum, pa'lante.
Y entonces esos jugadores tenían más contratos,
no simplemente esa media temporada.
Exactamente.
Vamos al GTAF, Adrián Blanco.
Te ha tocado por toda la suerte.
Sí, sí, sí.
Y pensaba...
Fíjate, cuando me tocó, dije...
Lo tengo.
Facilísimo.
Muy reciente.
¿Qué indices?
El Masón.
Mason Greenwood.
Ah, vale.
Está buscando en conexiones de...
El Masón.
Sí, sí.
A ver, a ver.
No sé cómo se le saludó Masón, pero ¿quién saludaba así?
Mason Greenwood.
Dije, ya está.
Por impacto, por nivel de futbolista, Mason.
Pero consulté.
Consulté con Usorio Arroba.
Cuidado.
Y le dije ¿será Greenwood?
Exactamente.
Y Usu me dijo no.
No es Mason Greenwood.
Es que ha tenido muchos cedidos.
Sobre todo los de Madrid.
Sí, Valencia.
Justo.
Ahí hay uno cedido por el Real Madrid.
Granero.
No.
De la Red.
Va a la Eurocopa jugando con el Getafe.
El año del Bayern.
Marca el penalti contra...
Grecia.
Grecia, en los últimos partidos.
La temporada en la que el Getafe llega a la final de copa
y cae en cuartos contra el Bayern.
Es una barbaridad.
Son nueve goles.
Cuando vuelve al Madrid, vuelve para ser el mediocentro.
Y vuelve...
Oye, ha jugado bien.
Vamos a darle una oportunidad.
No sé...
Sí, como Granero.
Sí, exactamente.
Granero que llega de año...
Creo que es con Pellegrini.
Sí, que se lesionó a Cristiano Ronaldo.
El debate era ¿juega al mejor en Madrid con Granero?
Te debate siempre es una mierda.
Cuando se lesione la mía mal y entre el que sea...
No, es que vas a jugar mejor sin la mía.
Cuesta ti, suga.
Estuvo solo una temporada en el Getafe.
Dani Huiza, que no lo hizo bien, son tres goles y una asistencia.
La otra vez en una entrevista...
El otro día con Pedro Arold dijo que se arrepiente
no haber elegido el Betis en aquella temporada.
Creo que se arrepentía del elegido Torrente.
Ah...
Es que le preguntó también.
Aquella entrevista no la hizo Pedro Arold.
Aquella fue la que dices la famosa de gol.
Pero no, el otro día habló con Pedro Arold
y dijo que Ibir lo que era aquel Betis,
que para él es la mejor afición de España,
y entre los Beticos dice,
ostras, más que la de Dani Huiza.
Huiza es el que es supermadridista
y dijo que se veía Real Madrid TV.
Era un jugador que no había jugado en Real Madrid
que en una entrevista me dice que sí,
que se ponía con el padevertido de los cadetes.
Los que echas él.
Sí, me sorprendió mucho con Huiza.
No es madrileño, no juega el Madrid.
Hay mucha gente así.
Para ponerse e enchufarse.
Huiza, Huiza Audio, ¿no?
En ese...
En ese cafelito con Pedro Arold.
No, no, no.
Tú, parcela.
Yo, yo quiero decir...
Yo la mía, ¿no?
Como cuando yo en mi casa,
cuando le echaba la bronca a mi hermano,
me cogí a mi madre por donde decía,
¿sabes que tu hermano tiene padre y madre?
Tú eres tu hermano mayor.
No, no, yo soy el hermano mayor de Joaquín Miranda.
Y yo a Joaquín Miranda no le podía echar la bronca
porque efectivamente Joaquín Miranda
tiene padre y madre.
Yo estoy pintado. A mí no.
A mí no. A mí no.
A Les D ya no hubiera entrado en este vídeo.
Antes de su regreso, sí.
En ese cafelito con Pedro Arold,
contó que me ha aparecido en TikTok
Dani Huiza que guardiola lo quiso fichar para el Barça.
Que lo quiso fichar para el Barça
pero que un peso pesado del Barça
se negó a que fichase porque no querían
que metiese la prensa rosa en el vestuario.
Esto lo contó Huiza el otro día.
No quería que metiese la prensa rosa
por si la prensa rosa encontraba...
Dijo que no, que Huiza no por esto.
Quiero jugar a quién.
¿Quién podría ser? A ver.
A ver, a ver.
No, no.
Yo creo que ha pillado guanquillo.
Recientemente del Barça.
Luis Enrique.
Chaby. A Chaby.
Pilla de Chaby.
Realmente del que siempre se ha dicho
que manda mucho en la sombra en el Barça.
Leo.
Pero tan joven aquella época.
Tampoco ha sido tan bueno como para negar a Huiza.
Cuidado.
Rubén de la Red.
En el caso del Getafe, por volver a lo que vimos.
En el caso del español, no sé si lo has dicho,
pero sería muy bueno Marco Asensio también.
No al nivel de Borja de Iglesias.
Son 4 goles. Onza asistencia.
Lucas Vázquez creo que es otro.
Si al final hay muchos jugadores cedidos,
sobre todo por Madrid.
Creo que más Madrid porque utiliza más esta estrategia.
Pero que al final son
de mucho nivel, de mucha proyección
y que tienen un gran impacto en ese sentido.
Le toca...
Alex.
Bueno, el Girona era muy fácil.
Todos teníamos la temporada
muy presente.
No, no.
Es muy fácil para Adri, para ti y para mí.
Para Adri y Deiano igual no.
Sorpréndenos.
Tienes que elegir.
La gente nos confunde.
Hay que elegir entre uno.
Hay dos para elegir.
Sí.
Yo creo que... Manat.
Podría ser...
O Abel Ruiz. Podría ser Osaviño o Doppik.
Lo hablé con Alex Luna y le dije Doppik
y me dijo que sí.
Doppik, Pichichi.
Vino, fue Pichichi, dejó pasta y se fue.
Mejor rendimiento que ese no puede haber.
Ahora bien, lo que estará echando de menos
Doppik a la caña.
A la perra del Girona.
La caña.
Cuando empezaste la frase creí que iba a decir a Michel
o a Montilivi.
La caña la pediría todos los días en el centro de entrenamiento.
La pediría en los partidos.
No me digáis nombres,
pero ¿es el mejor Doppik de toda la lista?
De momento diría que sí.
Mejor que el de Borger y Alesias.
La mejor que el de Flatan.
El año de Doppik superior al año de David Villa.
No digo el futbolista.
24 goles y le gasté 7.
No había ganado a Atlético de Madrid en cuántos años.
Pero yo creo...
En un equipo que todavía no había ganado
es el que te da todo eso.
Pero hay alguno más.
Vale, vale.
Nahuel Levante.
Bueno, aquí hay papá o mamá.
Aruna Cone o Felipe Caicedo.
Aruna Cone.
Claro.
Aruna Cone tiene mejores números globales.
Temporada 11-12.
Son 15 goles y 4 asistencias en 34 partidos.
Más de 2 goles en copa.
Claro.
Importante lo de los 2 goles en copa.
Porque al lado de Carlos Ayats,
que es la historieta, pero tiene miga,
con él tenía un pacto con el Sevilla
para quedarse con...
Con él tenía un pacto con Levante, perdón,
para quedarse con el 50% del traspaso.
El Weyan acaba pagando 6 millones de euros por él
al final de esa temporada.
¿Qué pasa? Que si llegaba a 18 goles
había una clausula del contrato por la que tenía que volver al Sevilla.
Entonces, fingieron una lesión en las últimas 3 jornadas
para que no llegara esa cifra, porque ya estaban 17.
Qué feo está el día.
En esas últimas 3 jornadas, Levante pierde en Zaragoza
y en Mallorca.
En Champions se queda 6º a 3º del Euro Málaga
y 6º del Valencia.
¿Pierde en Zaragoza? Sí, pierde en Zaragoza.
No es el partido... No, no, es al revés.
Es el de Ciudad, por eso.
De hecho, esto creo que es la temporada anterior,
si no recuerdo mal.
Tuviste que estar en juzgados.
Sí, cuando el presunto Mayo,
que no pudo ser demostrado,
de Levante Zaragoza.
Claro, el otro es...
Dicho lo cual, presunto o no, llevó a Nahuel Miranda
que tiene que estar fuera de un jugado.
Un mes y medio todos los días a las 8 de la mañana jugado.
Para mí...
Para mí bien hecho.
Para...
Lo sufrí yo como una condena.
La temporada anterior, ni Villa ni Agüero,
Felipe Caicedo, son 13 goles
y 2 asistencias en 28 partidos.
El Levante mete 41 solo esa temporada para poner un poquito.
Sí, sí.
El ratio es mejor que el de Cone, entre goles por minuto.
Y también en palabras de Carlos Ayads,
que ratifican varios empleados del club de la época,
hasta el jueves no entrenaba nunca.
Bueno, bueno.
A nivel calidad,
todo el mundo te dice que es el mejor jugador que ha pasado.
Sí, no.
El récord de Pepín, este famoso, no?
Tiene el...
El Levante.
No, el récord de goles, no?
Lo he visto aquí en el Museo de Repente.
No, no, no.
No me estáis claros.
Museo virtual de Levante.
El récord de Caicedo.
El que se tira a las 12.27 del mediodía, un miércoles 15 de octubre,
el famoso récord de Pepín.
Y esperar que le tiremos otra pared.
Claro, que caigues.
Y encima no lo preguntes, lo estás viendo.
Claro.
El récord de Caicedo, el granota que batió la marca goleadora
de Pepín en primera.
Ahí está.
Vale, yo me quedo con Cone.
De hecho, me parece un cañón hasta que se dice.
A ver, al final, Cone es el 9 del Euro Levante.
O sea, ya con esto debería estar.
Y te queda la duda de...
Si juegas esas tres jornadas, es que vos se mete en Champions.
¿Te queda la duda de Eta y John?
Claro.
¿Es capaz de poder superar esto?
Bueno, es que ha sido la granota.
Bueno, en la presentación
le preguntaron a Eta y John, se fijaba en Caicedo y Cone
y dice que me pide un poco lejos.
Yo sé de Pepín, pero de Caicedo.
Al final, el Levante se salva a la 33, chicos.
Ah, mira.
Lo dije.
Vale.
Tenemos siguiente caso Mallorca.
Mallorca, como soy escrupuloso con las normas,
no voy a nombrar a Juan Carlos Valerón
que estuvo en el 97-98.
Pues en el Real Oviedo te digo que va a ver qué hacer.
También es muy conocida la temporada de Luis García.
Después de haber estado en Murcia,
estaré en Mallorca, marcado 11 goles en la temporada 2004-2005.
Ah, muy bien.
Pero...
A ver.
Trampaca.
Trampaca, trampaca.
Ya verás.
No puedo poner a un canterano que juega en el Real Oviedo.
No puedo poner a un canterano que jugó 45 minutos y se marchó.
No puedo poner a Dani Huiza
que mete 27 goles y es pichiche en la 78.
Tengo alternativa.
¿Por qué no puedes poner a Huiza?
Porque jugó 45 minutos como canterano en otra temporada.
Ah, como...
No vale.
No te preocupes.
Cuando vas por la carretera y haces así,
¿qué quieres?
Que piten.
Sí.
¡Pandiani!
Temporada 2002-2003, campeón de copa.
También 18 goles en 50 partidos.
Marca la final, Pandiani.
La Copa del Rey es increíble.
Marca 5 goles en 7 partidos de aquella copa.
Y el 1-0 ante el Recre, que es un tercero,
el 1-0 ante el Recre,
esa final que no le gustaba Roberto Gómez,
lo marca Walter Pandiani.
No sé si os acordáis de esto,
pero Pandiani ya en la época de Osasuna
coincide con la primera temporada de Cristiano Ronaldo
en la Liga.
Le saca el beef con Cristiano Ronaldo.
Y le dice que cuando Cristiano gane
las Copas del Rey y las Supercopas que yo he ganado
aquí en España, va a poder hablar.
Le tiro ese beef.
Y esto se lleva a Antena 3,
a Cristiano Ronaldo,
al plato de informativos haciendo una entrevista
y le sacan el corte y dice
yo prefiero no pagar.
No sé si ha ganado más Copas
Cristiano Ronaldo que Pandiani.
¿Pandiani son tres?
Depor Mallorca y Español.
¿Y Español?
¿Y Cristiano?
Dos ¿no?
De Mestalla.
No puede hablar.
La temporada de Mallorca
es la segunda mejor temporada de Pandiani
en toda su carrera.
La superazó la del Depor.
Cristiano Busset-Kalabok.
Esperemos que ahora le pongan esto.
A mí me ha quedado raro.
Nos lo traigan a plato.
Pandiani estuvo en Osasuna, que es el siguiente club,
que es el de Ciudad Blanco.
¿Quién fue memorable allí en un año?
Dos opciones.
Una reciente.
Se sale hace una Copa Espectacular.
Llega a la final.
Pero hay otro mejor, que es el Goudari.
¿El Goudari?
Es en búsqueda Soldado.
A veces ha tenido otro contexto.
Aclarame un poquito.
El Goudari, Roberto Soldado,
la conocí así.
Temporada 6-7.
El Goudari.
La vida viene por aquí.
Infiltrado.
Semifinal web pa' entel Sevilla aquella temporada.
13 goles como decía.
Me ha asustado cuando ha dicho eso.
Y lo convoca Luis Ardabonés
para la clasificación de la Euro 2008.
Yo cuando escuchaba el Goudari he dicho...
Este era mí.
No lo tenía.
¿Quién era el otro que no era como un AM?
El Masut.
El portero.
Sí, no se me ha ido.
Entre...
Que es Aguate.
Mejor amigo de Gustavo.
No es precisamente Irani.
Vaya ducha.
Aguate y Gustavo.
Soldado.
Soldado, soldado.
13 goles.
En el Villarreal Marco 12.
Alex Oviedo.
Jugador memorable que estuvo un máximo de un año
en primera división.
En primera división.
A ver, dime por dónde quieres que te haga la trampa.
Por segunda división o por siglo XXI?
Porque tengo muy buenos.
Es que tengo uno muy bueno.
¿Para qué preguntas?
Te digo el del siglo XXI también.
Venga, a ver.
Te lo digo o no.
El de fuera del siglo XXI.
Esto de lo digo o no lo digo era muy de flow.
Sí.
Pero tenías las justas.
Tienen cositas de flow.
No.
Ah, Procineki. Procineki, pero claro.
Ojalá tener el churro que tenía.
O hasta que te rías.
Había una sección.
Hacerle ir al contable.
Qué verano aquel.
Pero como no se vale lo del siglo XXI.
Solo fue un verano.
No, el verano de Alex fue...
Yo vivía un verano constante.
Yo recuerdo un verano solo.
Yo creo que el pic fue un verano.
Entonces, Kaabriga Diego me ha dicho...
Me ha dicho lo de Procineki.
Y también me ha dicho Lunin.
En segunda división.
Que dejó un recuerdo muy importante.
Lunin que fue claramente suplente, ¿no?
No, no, no.
Fue titular.
Eso fue en Valladolid.
No, en Leganes.
De hecho, llega...
Es imposible que no haya otro mejor.
No llega a trolear.
Con el equipo.
En decimoséptima posición.
Y lo deja a decimocuarto.
Con seis porterías a cero, nada más ni nada menos.
En 20 partidos.
Estuvo muy bien Lunin.
Y es verdad que la gente le guarda muy buen recuerdo novieto a Lunin.
20 partidos.
Ah, es verdad que aquí estaba incluso fuera de segunda.
Mucho tiempo.
Estuvo un año y medio Abel Bertones.
Que fue el que yo...
Estuvo Leo Román.
Un año y medio Román.
Sergián Rit.
Un año.
Estuvo Leo Román también en una temporada.
No, no, no.
Estaba con Correa.
Es que te metes tú solo.
Te metes tú solo y luego te quedas.
No, no.
Miguel, es que...
Raya, no vuelve y anda.
Es que este es muy fácil.
Porque hay un vestigio en el estadio de Vallecas.
En el estadio de Vallecas.
Que así claro.
O sea, has dicho así claro porque...
¿Qué vas a decir Michu?
No, no. Michu es uno. Falcao.
El Chori Domínguez.
Tony Polster.
Polster y Hugo Sánchez.
Me parece que no entran en el siglo XXI.
Diego Costa está seis meses.
Me lo recordaba a Palovilla.
Le preguntó también a Irra.
Hemos hablado de Larry Bay.
Pero todos los partidos en el estadio de Vallecas.
Me he sacado una bandera de Uruguay y una de Peñarol por Fernando Morena.
Que claro, era el mi nombre hasta recordarlo del siglo XXI.
El siglo XXI, claro.
Así que me va a quedar con Michu.
Es que Fernando Morena era perfecto.
21 goles en 34 partidos.
Le echabais una coleta de la bandera de Uruguay.
¿Y a qué año es?
80. 79-80.
De hecho, Morena tiene una estatua.
No entra aquí.
Pero lo he comprobado.
Está Saúl también.
Saúl lo hace muy bien como central.
Pero también marca que deja el rayo en primera.
Histórico.
Lo deja en el descenso, ¿no?
No, no.
Con Michu la gente se acuerda mucho.
Baja el día real.
Aquella temporada.
Es una temporada muy potente.
Creo que había ciertas similitudes
entre Michu y Larry Bay en cuanto a estilo de juego.
Pero vamos.
Ese Michu antes de explotar y salir por una misera
son 15 goles y 4 asistencias
entre 27 partidos temporada 11-12.
Real Madrid.
A bote pronto, creo que todos
nos acordamos como eso que decíamos
de Dorlan Pavón y estas historias.
Manuelito Adubayor.
Por carisma.
Hablamos de memorable, igual entraría él.
No vale José Lumato
según vosotros porque jugó 20 minutos
en dos partidos.
Por cierto, marcó dos goles en 20 minutos
en dos partidos con el Real Madrid.
En la cesión... ¿Excesión?
No me acuerdo.
Es una cesión del español del Real Madrid.
Marca 17 goles en el Real Madrid
los famosos Albayor.
Aquí hay
dos opciones.
Una, que está seis meses
bien,
juntera.
Sí, porque corre el ADR.
Sí, pero creo que está luego
un poco más.
Juega 20 partidos, marca 8 goles.
No está más.
20 partidos en la segunda vuelta.
Yo creo que debió estar media temporada,
otra media y luego se fue.
Al Salque, ¿no?
Son 20 de la 2008-2009.
Se va al Milan.
Y está la temporada
de un balón de oro.
Hay que quedarse con él como me quedo con Zlatan Ibrahimovic
en el Barça. Mike Lowe.
Que marca 16 goles en 55 partidos.
La gente tiene un recuerdo
negativo porque...
Primero, sí,
con el puntín.
Siempre que ponían a Owen
en el Madrid ponían ese gol.
También Frankesey
marco en un clásico.
Ibra,
estuvo en la segunda temporada y marco en un clásico.
Ese gol en el segundo palo.
Tiene mal recuerdo porque
le quita el balón de oro precisamente
a Raúl.
Es época galáctica y dices
que no estuvo mal.
No encajó.
Yo creo que por carisma sería Adebayor
igual que sería David en el Barça
por rendimiento neto.
Y 16 goles.
No está mal.
Real Sociedad, Zadri.
Me iba a quedar con Martin Odegaard.
Muy buena.
Pero no.
Me han corregido nuestros cómpies desde Donosti.
Me han dicho que no es el mejor
fotolista que ha estado solo una temporada.
Juguemos.
No.
Es la etapa 2002-2003.
Michael Artheta.
No, no.
Juego fatal en la Real.
¿Por qué lo dices?
Porque por su madre.
Porque has dicho Finn Bogason ahora.
Irónico.
Eso es lo peor, que no es irónico.
Es que es lo peor.
No le puedes echar la bronca a tu hermano.
Tiene un padre y tiene una madre.
Temporada 2002-2003.
¿2003?
No, no.
¿5 o 6?
¿Es Darko?
No.
Ni Ni Hat.
Carpin.
Cedido por un equipo inglés.
Joder.
Tiene un impacto fuerte.
El equipo inglés.
El Liverpool.
Ustras.
Marca 5 goles y es clave para que la Real
no baje esa temporada.
Y es mejor que Odegaard.
Para Eneko Pica Bea, sí.
Es quien me ha ayudado con esto.
Mar González.
Un golazo le falta, si no me equivoco.
Uno de ellos ante el Racing.
Estaba leyendo un poco crónicas.
Lo juegan el Betis.
Y salva a la Real de descender aquella temporada.
Y para Eneko, mejor que Martín Odegaard.
Yo hubiera elegido Martín Cho.
Yo a Eneko.
Porque 7 goles, 9 asistencias.
El nivel fue espectacular.
Y la Real más divertida del ciclo de Manoli.
Pero bueno, hay 2.
¿Tienes un nombre?
Sí.
¿Cuántas normas infringe?
No, no, no.
¿A qué plantas normas?
Quiero volver al Rayo porque tenía muy atado lo de Fernando Morena.
No había caído lo del siglo XXI.
Te honra.
Honor.
Aura.
Para empezar, Falcao y El Chori tienen más de una temporada.
¿Has dicho alguno bien?
Es que...
En fin...
Necesitaba nombres a Cholón.
Cuando tengo uno, descarto los demás.
Pero lo de Diego Costa y Norbya fue tan bestia.
Fue increíble.
10 goles, 4 asistencias en 6 meses.
En 16 partidos.
Temporada 11-12.
Diego Costa y Michu, los dos ahí.
Cuando Diego Costa llega a la Atlético de Madrid,
porque está en varias sesiones,
su rendimiento no está tan bien.
El rendimiento no es tan sorprendente por esos meses en el Rayo.
No sé si me explico.
Transladarlo es muy complicado.
Pero ya eran 6 meses que eran brutales.
Después de esto,
es cuando dice Cholo Simion de estas sesiones,
cuando dice Simion aquello que habla con Diego Costa
al principio de una pre-temporal,
y dice, Diego, búscate equipo mientras entrenas aquí.
Y cada día que lo veía entrenarse quería matar.
Sí, sí.
Eh...
Álex, Sevilla.
¿Por qué Anthony Martial?
No.
Aquí hemos tirado de Ayuda Divina.
¿Vale? Pedilo.
Y sí, Ramón Verdejo Monchi.
¿Te lo ha dicho Monchi? Sí.
A través de un buen amigo que conocemos todos.
Ha dicho un nombre.
Pero un nombre que no entra.
Que no puede entrar. Se ha equivocado Monchi.
¿Sí? Se ha equivocado Monchi.
A ver, porque claro...
Ayuda Infernal. El nombre era...
El nombre que había sugerido...
O sea, que lo había Monchi. Era Jeffrey Condos Pia.
Ah, muy bueno. Claro, era muy bueno.
Pero jugó 90 minutos
en dos partidos de Liga, en la 13-14.
¿Cuándo se va? 15 minutos
en el clasificatorio para la Europa League,
la fase previa. Entonces no entra.
Es cuando se va al Inter. Sí, es cuando se va al Inter.
Pero yo tenía... Mal Monchi, eh.
Ahí hay que mejorar, eh.
Yo tenía... No, no. Muchas gracias
a nuestro amigo y compañero Alonso Rivero,
que luego también ha hecho bien a preguntarle a Monchi.
Eh... Pero yo tenía tres nombres antes.
Eh...
Os voy a decir mi favorito. Os voy a decir los que descarto.
¿Cuál es mi favorito? Vale.
Eh... Jovetic podría ser uno,
que tuvo un impacto muy fuerte. 6 goles,
4 asistencias, jugó 24 partidos.
Marcó además uno en Copa del Rey.
Al Madrid, ¿no? Jovetic
fue el debut. Fue el debut. Sí.
Jovetic era el que aprendió español
con los serrano. Se dijo hasta que mi arma
es veñeder. Sí, sí, sí.
Eso es. Eh...
Cuidado. Mezclároslo en otros temas.
Estaba Seidou Keita, que luego
se marcha al Barça. Seidou Keita
es muy bueno, eh. Muy bueno. Aparece en otro club
se digo Keita.
De... Ah, vale.
Claro, puede ser. Con otro equipo que empiece por V.
Y luego está
el que es mi favorito, que es Samir Nari.
Sí. Que en el...
Sobre todo la primera vuelta con San Paolo y...
Antes de la visita aquella a la clínica.
De la clínica. No sé.
La foto aquella de la clínica. La foto de la clínica.
Me acuerdo. Una foto con dos enfermeras
que se hizo muy viral cuando se decía que se había dopado.
De hecho, Samir Nari se la acusó.
Bueno, de hecho, ¿estuvo parado o no?
Creo que no y...
A nivel oficial creo que no.
Creo que era un poco... Estuvo parado ese día.
Estuvo parado. Hubo un día que se puso.
No me entendí. Pero es que lo de Nari,
igual que aquel sería de San Paolo, fue la primera vuelta.
Sí. Luego en febrero tiene eliminatoria
contra el Leicester en Champions. A raíz de la eliminatoria
contra el Madrid de Copa, creo que ya se cae.
Es cuando empieza el Sevilla, la sección argentina
a tantear a San Paolo. ¿Se acordáis del partido debut?
Sí, contra el...
Esto lo repasamos.
Creo que es un 6-4 contra el español.
Sí, de Quique Sánchez Flores.
El partido es increíble. El partido es espectacular.
Silencio. Juega el mudo.
Valencia. Nahuel Miranda.
Estoy flipando con las fotos de esta red.
De Nari. No os acordáis a aquella foto.
¿Cuál ha sido tu búsqueda en Google?
Nari, enfermera. Nari, foto, clínica.
Ah, pues ya está.
Y ya te van a aparecer.
¡Jajaja!
Estoy alucinando.
Vale, dale. Voy a cerrar la piscina.
Hay un artículo que es
las mejores imágenes
de las enfermeras que han tenido.
Ya. Pasemos.
En el Valencia
el primero en el que pensé fue Romario.
Pero claro, primero. No es siglo XXI.
Y segundo es que estuvo dos temporadas.
Son 11 partidos. Además, ha quedado
un icono de la ciudad.
Y me ha sorprendido que haya jugado tan poco.
De los recientes...
La noche. Claro.
Sí, bueno, es que hay galitos
que tenía que decir...
Nosotros somos el galito favorito de Romario.
En el pick de la noche Valencia.
Es como cuando Maradona era
el mejor del calcio en la mejor etapa
de la historia del calcio. Claro, justo.
De los recientes está Justin Kluivert
que dejó buen recuerdo. Pero claro,
no al nivel de otros.
Y Klik también estuvo un año.
Su padre. Claro, sí.
Pero fue muy pasado de vueltas.
Está Nelson Aedo Valdés
por ahí, que también
muy buen recuerdo.
Y Seidu Keita que hace
una segunda vuelta espectacular.
¿Es solo segunda vuelta? Sí, con el Valencia de Pizzi.
Que es también el de la remontada
de la Asinéa, el reto de Paco Alcácer.
Juega también Vargas, que también
es uno de los nombres que podemos traer.
Pero ya es el nombre que tienes claro.
¿Sabes cuál es? No.
Sigue en activo.
Está jugando Champions, de hecho.
Es internacional por su selección.
Va a jugar la finalísima. Sí.
Estamos hablando de Nicolás Utameni.
Es irrelatible.
35 partidos, 6 goles.
Meta el Valencia en Champions. Es capitán.
6 goles siendo central.
Espectacular.
La historia es curiosa
porque el Valencia lo firma
en enero de 2013,
y decidió inscribir.
No tenía cupos extracomunitarios.
Decidió inscribir a Vinicio Sarraúso,
que es un futbolista que juega en el Zaragoza
y en el Huesca.
Se queda cedido en Atlético Mineiro,
llega el Valencia en uno
y hace una temporada espectacular junto a Mustafi.
Y se marcha vendido a Manchester City
en el verano del 14.
También le hubiese sido uno más en el Valencia Bronco
y Copero. En cualquier Valencia.
Y ya para finalizar, cerramos con el Villarreal.
Aquí tengo muy buenos recuerdos del pato
y el Villarreal, el jugador siempre me ha fascinado.
Evidentemente
tenemos el caso
Tierno Barri.
O sea, de Jogooles, Twitch, Streams
y millones. De todo.
Pas completo, pero creo que el mejor
es Pabgay
antes de Pabgay.
Ah, digo no.
Como nos cuida.
¿Quién fue Pabgay antes de Pabgay?
Zambon Giza.
Que estaba hacedo por el Fulán.
Y fue un temporada increíble.
Creo que tenía una opción de compra.
No está mal, pero se iba de madre para ese Villarreal
en el Napoli.
Está siendo uno de los capitanes generales.
Nivelazo de escándalo.
Y era un ganador.
Fue un tipo de futbolista que es muy técnico
pero físicamente sobresaliente en la Liga se nota mucho.
Fíjate que yo creía que iba a salir
con uno que hizo carrera en la Liga
que jugó también en el Atlético de Madrid,
en el Valencia y en el Sevilla.
Delantero. Bieto. Luciano Bieto.
El de Bieto y de Niser y Ser de Marseille.
Sí, que son...
Se igualen 5 asistencias en 10 partidos de Europa League
y 12 más 2 en 32 de Liga.
Podría ser, eh. Podría ser Bieto.
Pero Zambon Giza es una barbaridad.
Pues con él cerramos. Juegadores memorables
que estuvieron un año más o menos
en el siglo XXI, más o menos
en los equipos de la Liga.
Eso sí. Más o menos.